what is very important in our
work is indeed and it is
thanks to mathematica that we can do
it originally I am an engineer and the world
of para is the mechanics of thousands
continue in particular the mechanics of
materials of  structure
the interest of mathematica for me at
the time was the ability to be able
to do computer algebra and to make it
interact with its formal calculations with a
numerical calculation
and then in the architecture where I
currently work I teach in
a  school of architecture the rights
of architecture of paris malaquais and i
also teach at the school of ponts
paristech which is an
engineering error the two schools i do
roughly the same types of teaching
it is design  of structures and
the use of materials in
structures
I am currently a dozen
doctoral students in the laboratory I master the
textural narrative which is at the School
of Paris Malaquais etc others
all work
with mathemat  ics because it
actually allows us this
very important interaction today to let go
in architecture between image and
logic and kindergarten and
mathematics
that's this project there is an evolution
in my report and mathematics
at the beginning c  it was above all the computer
algebra it would have fallen on the
few digital ones
today we do more like a lot
more calculations but what a computer algebra
but on the other hand this interaction
with geometry with the possibility of
dialogue with architects and
with interfaces and d  'other programs
for exporting in other formats
useful for manufacturing which which is
which takes precedence in the use of mathematics
firstly there is the scientific aspect
indeed mathematica but allows
us allows I think I can
also speak a year of the  The railcar that I
work allows us to have
continuity between the logic beyond the
problem as we understand it from a
formal point of view of a  fundamental point of view
its programming
and then the exploitation of these results
so there is a great continuity, that is
to say that the alternative would be to
use many different tools
or perhaps tic which are which seeks to
be  also con as wide less
complete so it gives me at the same time
the magnitude to say that starting
from gives many root causes
to get to
applications without changing software and
in a way that makes that  in fact
we never need to resort to
other other questions that's a first
point so that I would say that purely from
the scientific quality of the thing in
second element it is for me as
a professor of the  pedagogy
indeed I liked that
mathematics in two ways in
pedagogy to show something
correct well drawn to
calculate well to students at infinity so
without alteration that is a first type
2 2
result which is  very important for me
and the other is to develop
with students do not necessarily have a
doctorate first-
year students to develop tools or
procedures that allow them to
understand a little bit the basics the
foundations  algorithms and
science is something that is very
important in the echoes of architecture
the third important element is
precisely in communication we
work in a border that
connects members in the world of fairies
witnessing the  'architectured the world of dark science
and engineering
we are working on a border
that connects
demands architecture engineering and its
demands in front of defeating uses to
dialogue by terms i would say
they are which belongs to it and  which
sometimes keep communication difficulties
against the images
fortunately are often make us that
everyone can speak and
understand even if match so that
p  ermits actually third thing
mathematically allows us in the end
after we have kept all our rigor
and love for mathematics for
logic we can arrive at a
final result which is exportable in another
culture without difficulty